اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى بانوراما نناقش فيها كالعاده
ابرز ملفات اليوم وفي ملفات هذا المساء
قمه المناخ ما هو تاثير الظرف العالمي
وازمه الطاقه على القمه هذا العام وهل
ستكون قمه المضيق دمى في تنفيذ الالتزامات
ام في تاجيلها
الموضوع الثاني هل رياده العالم ستستمر في
الولايات المتحده ام ستنتقل الى دوله اخرى
ومن هي الدوله الاخرى التي يمكن ان تحل
محلها
لحظه فارقه عنوانه قمه المناخ
التي توفت العشرات من قاده العالم الى مصر
للمشاركه فيها بشرم الشيخ ودعاء رئيس
المصريه عبد الفتاح السيسي الى تحرك سريعا
لوضع خريطه طريق تحمي العالم من تاثيرات
التغيرات المناخيه مؤكدا ان بلاده تتطلع
لخروج المؤتمر من مرحله الوعود الى مرحله
التنفيذ باجراءات ملموسه تبني او تبني على
مخرجات فعلا قمه باريس
كبير لتعزيز تعهداتهم المناخيه اذا
الاحترار الاخري بالارتفاع
الماليه لدول الفقيره اكثر المتضررين من
التغير المناخي وتاتي القمه وسط ازمات
متعدده ابرزها الحرب في اوكرانيا والتضخم
وازمه الطاقه وازمه الغذاء في وقت سيتجاوز
عدد وكان العالم ثمانيه مليارات نسمه
ويتراقب العالم الاعلانات المتعلقه
بالمساعدات الى دول الفقيره وهي عاده اكثر
البلدان عرضه لتداعيات الاحترار المناخي
رغم ان مسئوليتها فيه محدوده حيث ان
انبعاثاتها من الغازات الدفيئه قليله جدا
وقد قرر المندوبون الى القمه للمره الاولى
ادراجه تمويل الاضرار الناجمه عن الاحترار
في جدول الاعمال الرسمي للمؤتمر وتقدر هذه
الاضرار بعشرات المليارات من الدولارات
فالفيضانات الاخيره التي غمرت ثلث باكستان
تسببت وحدها باضرار قدرت اكثر من ثلاثين
مليار دولار
انا بتكلم تحديدا هنا على الازمه الروسيه
الاوكرانيه
وبوجه النداء
بكم ومعكم من اجل ان تتوقف هذه الحرب
من اجل ان تتوقف هذه الحرب لتحقيق اهداف
المرجوه من مبادره الشرطه الاخضر الطموحه
يتطلب باستمرار التعاون الاقليمي
والاسهامات الفعاله من قبل الدول الاعضاء
في الوصول الاهداف المناخيه العالميه
وتنفيذ الالتزاماتها لواتيره اسرع في اطار
اتفاقيات الدوليه ذات الصلع
وكانت الامارات اول دوله
في المنطقه
تعلن مبادره استراتيجيه لتحقيق الحياد
المناخي
بحلول عام 20 50
ان دوله الكويت تؤكد التزامها بالقرارات
والمبادرات الخليجيه والاقليميه والدوليه
المعنيه بالبيئه
فقد تضمنت رؤيه الكويت جديده
2020 35
ركيزه اساسيه محورها بيئه نعيشيه
المستدامه تسعى من خلالها الى تحقيق
الاستدامه البيئيه
اون لاين
في مواجهه التغير المناخي ونحن نخسر
ارتفاع درجات الحراره حول العالم مستمر
والخطر كبير الحرب في اوكرانيا والصراعات
واعمال العنف القط بظلالها على العالم
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من باريس
دكتور حسان تليليا المتخصص في سياسه
التنميه والبيئه اهلا بك ومن الخبر نايفه
دانيال خبير في استراتيجيات الطاقه اهلا
بكمين واسمحالي ان ابدا من السعوديه من
الخبر بتحديد معك يا استاذنا يا استاذ
نايف اااه
الدائم الدائر بين المناخيين انصح التعبير
المدافعين عن المناخ والصناعيين امم الاول
يقول المدافع عن المناخ يقول بان الصناعه
هي المتسبب الاول والابرز في تدهور البيئه
الصناعيون يقولون بانهم بالعكس همم هناك
مشاكل سياسيه هي التي تضر بالبيئه هناك
حروق ولكن الصناعه هي همم شيء حياتي حضرتك
كيف ترى الامور من حمل المسؤوليه ومن يجب
ان نستمع له عند طرحه لمثل هكذا مبررات
مساء الخير اهلا بكم انا اظن انه اظن انه
ما في احد لا من المناخيين ولا من
الصناعيين
اظن انه ما في احد ينكر اهميه المناخ
وحساسيه الموضوع وحتميه
لسلامه
يعيش على على هذا الكوكب التغيير المناخي
همم اظن انه حقيقه الخلاف قد يكون في
السياسه التي تنتهي لمعالجه هذا التغير
المناخي همم ما هي الاستراتيجيه التي يجب
ان ننتهجها ما هي السياسات التي همم
المفترض ان تتبعها كيف يكون موضوع
الانتقال الثلث ما هي همم ما هي الوسائل
الاسلم لانه هناك الحقيقي
لكن عديده من العالم لا تجد اي مصدر من
مصادر الطاقه لا لا تملك المقاطع خلينا
نتكلم شويه بصراحه الوسائل الاسلم التي
تتحدث حضرتك عنها هي الوسائل الاكثر ضررا
بالنسبه لدول الصناعيه تروج همم هذه الدول
ومنها دول الاوروبيه حقيقه لخطاب يتحدث عن
وجوب ايجاد هذه الوسائل ولكن حقيقه هناك
سباق نحو التصنيع لهذه الدول خلينا نخرج
راي الدكتور حسان في هذا الموضوع دكتور
حسن ما رايك
مساء الخير بالنسبه الى مشاهدي قناتكم
الحقيقه ان هناك
كما ذكرت من قبل البلدان الاوروبيه هناك
موقفان اثنان الموقف المبدئي وهو موقف
سليم من الناحيه المبدايه وهو ان التخلص
من مصادر الوقود الاحفوري ضروره للحفاظ
على كوكب الارض والحفاظ على
العمليه التنمويه المستدامه
والحقيقه ان بلدان كثيره من الجنب ادرك
ذلك وفهم ذلك يعني اذكر مشاهدي قناتكم
البلدان الخليجيه النفطيه في البدايه كانت
تتحفظ قبل قرون قبل عقود ولكنها شيئا
فشيئا اهتدت فعلا الى اهميه الطرح القائل
ان الوقود الاحفوري لا ينبغي ان نعول عليه
100% ولكن علينا ان اولا
نستثمر فيه مصادر الطاقه الجديده
والمتجدده وما تفعله المملكه العربيه
السعوديه مثلا اليوم ما تفعله مثلا اليوم
الدوله الامارات العربيه ودول اخرى في
الاستثمار في الطاقه الشمسيه في الاقتصاد
الاخضر ومع ذلك فدوى الغربيه مثلا اعطيك
مثل اليوم في كلمه الرئيس ماكرون المانيا
الرئيس الفرنسي يعني اعاد في الحقيقه
تدوير كلام كان يقال من قبل وقال لابد من
التخلص من الفحم الحجري
واكد على تعزيز مصادر الطاقه الجديده
ولكنه اكد كثير على الطاقه الذريه الناس
كلهم يعرفون انه ليس في متناول كل البلدان
ان تملك التكنولوجيا الضروريه لاداره
الطاقه الذريه وبالتالي فرنسا من كبار
البلدان التي تملك هذه التكنولوجيا
وتصدرها ما ياخذه وما البيئه والمدافع عن
البيئه اليوم عن مثل هذا الموقف ان فيه
رؤيه فيها ااا ان شئت نظره الى المصالح
الفرنسيه قبل ان ننظر الى العالم كما لو
كان قريه صغيره
وبيتا واحدا يسكنه كل الناس يعني هذه في
الحقيقه مفارقه تبدو اليوم في موقف بعض
البلدان الغربيه او بالاحرى غالبيه
البلدان المتقدمه اليوم ساعود لك الى هذه
النقطه وخاصه الى الوضع همم العالم الحالي
وهمم التحديات الحاليه كذلك وعلاقتها
بالمناخ ولكن استاذ نايف قرات بعض
التعليقات المدافعين على على المناخ
يقولون بانه همم من المبالغه الحديث او من
المبالغه تحميل همم
المسؤوليه الى الدول الصناعيه لانه همم
مساله المناخ او حمايه المناخ اكبر من ذلك
همم هل حقيقه مساله مناخ تت ده المساله
التصنيع او التصنيع يضر بها في نسبه كبيره
من الموضوع
اعتقد المشكله الحقيقيه اللي نواجهها الان
هي في تحديد الهدف في موضوع الانبعاثات
الكربوني الى الان همم في هجوم كبير ومنهج
واستهداف للوقود الاحفوري بدنا نشوف يعني
الخطابات السياسيه
والاجنده انه دعونا نتخلص اليوم من من كل
همم كل انواع الوقود الاحفوري لان نفطر
الغاز همم الفحم الحجري
ولكنها اصبحت اصنام الجاهليه اذا جاعوا
واكلوها
عندما يعني عندما تحتاجها هذه الدول وهذا
اا اصحاب السياسات والاجنده الاجنده في
موضوع المناخ هرعوا اليها وطلب المزيد
منها ويعني لام وحتى من يصدرون ومن ينتجون
بانهم مقلين في هذا الانتاج ويريد نقص
اكثر وغاز اكثر وفحم اكثر المشكله يعني
لما اقول انا ليش ما في تحديد يجب ان نحدد
الهدف يجب ان نحدد السياسات احنا انا
دائما باقول انه خلونا نستهدف الانبعاثات
لا نستهدف المصادر ما عندنا الرفاهيه الان
على الاقل على الاقل في الوقت الحالي اذا
كنا 70% من مصادر الطاقه ياتي من الوقود
الاحفوري اذا سبع مئه مليون انسان لا
يجدون اي مصدر اي مصدر ما عندهم مره فهي
الاختيار
اي مصدر من مصادر الطاقه
للطاقه الى اثنين مليون و600 2 مليار و600
مليون لا يجدون مصدر للوصول الى الماء
النظيف والطبخ النظيف ومع ذلك ياتي من
يقول انه تخلص من الوقود الاحفوري بالكامل
انا اقول انه خلونا نتخلص من الانبعاثات
ما نتخلص من الوقود الاحفوري اذا كان اذا
كان اذا كان الامر كذلك فليكن ولكن لا
نعرف
العالم الان لمشكله حقيقيه يحتاج فيها كل
ذره سواء النفط او كل ذره غاز والفحم
الحجري المسؤول الاكبر الان اوروبا الان
مثلا الذي مركز النداءات والولايات
المتحده انظري للاسعار وانظري للطلب
العالمي على ايه يعني غير مسموح
استاذ استاذ نايف هي عادت فعليا مع الحجر
المانيا عاده الدنمارك عادت وبدات بعض
المصانع همم يعني تعيد استعمال الفحم
الحجري لتوليد الكهرباء خاصه بعد ازمه
الغاز ولكنك حضرتك اعتبرت بان هناك
استراتيجيه منهجه وهناك سوء نيه في
استهداف همم
المصادر وليست الانبعاثها تبتسم لاني سال
اسال وسطرح همم عن همم الى ضيف هذا السؤال
همم دكتور حسان هل هناك فعلا سوء نيها في
استهداف المصدر وليس الانبعاثات تعتقد
الواقع ان هناك كما ذكرت في بدايه هذه
المداخله وهذا النقاش ان هناك مصالح لدى
البلدان الغربيه ومنها تنطلق لتحمل على
الوقود الاحفوري ومع ذلك فان اتفاق باريس
واضح في هذا اتفاق باريس الذي امرنا عام
2015 ودخل الحيز التنفيذ في نوفمبر عام
2016 اي في اليوم تقريبا الاول الذي بدات
فيه قمه مراكش
وكانت في ذلك الوقت همم 22 يعني
اتفاق باريس واضح لابد من الحد من
الانبعاثات هذه الانبعاثات مصدرها الاساسي
على تصريحات همم مختلف هذه الدول ومواقف
هذه الدول ما قالته وما فعلته بعد ذلك
ولكن حدثني عن رايك عن رؤيتك انت هل تعتقد
بان هناك استراتيجيه منهجا لاستهداف
المصادر وليس الانبعاثير
لا طبعا الانبعاثات مصدرا الانبعاثات
عندما نقول لا لا علينا الا نتحدث عن
الوقود الاحفوري بل نتحدث عن الانتحاثات
جانب كبير من هذه الانبعاثات مصدرها
الوقود الاحفوري لا يمكن لا يمكن ان ننكر
ذلك ثم ان
المصادر الطاقه الجديده والمتجدده هو افق
بالنسبه للبلدان الناميه البلدان الخليجيه
والبلدان العربيه فيها الشمس فعلا ترويض
الشمس همم
مساله حياتيه بالنسبه الى شعوب العالم
كلها وبالتالي باتفاق باريس يقول لا يمكن
ان ننتقل بين ليله واخرى من الوقود
الاحفوري الى مصادر الطاقه
في انه يجب القضاء على همم او التخفيف او
تحجيم المصادر
وبطبيعه الحال س سي ينعكس ذلك على
الانبعاثات صحيح
نعم
خليني اخذ راي الاستاذ نايف فهمت
فتره ليست قصيره
الحياه الكربوني اللي انت لازم تصل الى
صافي
0-300 بمعنى انك انت تنتج للنظف ولكن انك
خلال العمليات هذه اي اي ذرات او اي حجم
من الانبعاثات الكربونيه هذه يجب ان
تتسامهم اما في تقليل هذا الحجم انك انت
ما يصدر منك اي ام بي عرفات كربونيه او
انك انت تساهم بتكنولوجيا او باجراءات
تخفض نفس الحجم اللي انت ساهمت فيه
الانبعاثات الكربونيه الان مثلا خليني
اضرب لك عده امثله همم انه التقاط الكربون
وتخزين الكربون من الجرو وهذه احد همم
الوسائل اللي همم فيها تخفيض الانبعاثات
الكربوليه لاي مشغل بيعمل في الوقود
الاحفوري او حتى على مستوى الحكومات وعدد
مستوى الدول النقطه الاخرى مثل ثاني زراعه
اشجار وخصوصا اشجار المانجروف اللي هي
تستهلك كميه كبيره من ثاني اكسيد الكربون
هذه تزرع الان سواء في المملكه تزرع في
الامارات تزرع فيها اماكن
متعدده من العالم
طبعا احنا لا هالحين ما وصلنا الى مرحله
النضج ولذلك الحياد الكربوني العالم
تستغرب انه ليش 20 50 مثلا بعد 30 سنه
السبب لانه ما عندناش في التكنولوجيا اللي
تسعدنا انه نوصل الى صفر صافينانيه لازم
نبدا من اي مكان لازم نبدا الان نعم
الجميع بدا الان ولكن في تفريج بين
المصادر وفي تفريج بين الانبعاثات نقدر
نتحكم بالانبعاتات مع مع انه نحاول يعني
لا فرج او انه ناخذ اكبر فائده من المصادر
الحاليه لرفاهيه الناس ولا حتى مو
للرفاهيتهم الحقيقه اللي اعطاهم الحد
الادنى من مستويات المقبوله معيشيا في
الوصول الى الطاقه وممارسه حياه المطربين
طبيعي
في الانبعاثات وكذلك حتى وجهات النظر
المختلفه لكل هذه الدول المجتمعه في كوب
22 ومع كل دوله ومصالحها وحساباتها كذلك
سياسيه ولا استراتيجيه وحسابات المستقبليه
هل تعتقد بانه هذا المؤتمر
سيخرج همم شيء فعلي بورقه فعليه بالتزامات
فعليه ام ان هذا مؤجل نحن في بدايه الطريق
نحن ندرس نتشارك افكار وربما سياتي يوما
لتشكيل اليا ناجحه
الكاب 8 واللي قبلوا على الاقل اتخذوا
خطوه ممتازه الان بالجلوس مع الشركات
النقيه والمنخرطين في صناعه الوقود
الاحفوري وهذا الحقيقه شيء ايجابي جدا
بحيث انه يسمع صوت التحديات اللي تواجه
هذه الشركات وهذه همم خلينا نسميهم اصحاب
المصادر همم
وكيف يمكن معالجتها لانه لا يمكن ان تسمع
صوت واحد بدون ما تسمع تحديات اللي تواجه
الطرف الاخر ايجابي جدا في شرم الشيخ انه
في الانهامه من الشركات التصفيه ونتقم على
طاوله المباحثات تحديات الاتجاهاتها
وبالتالي الحوار والنقاش ان شاء الله
حيفني الى نتائج ملموسه على الاقل تضعنا
على بدايه الطريق وهو عنوان القمه الان في
شرم الشيخ
متابعه مخرجات هذه القمه وتشكركم الجزيره
شكرا على المشاركه في موضوعنا الاول من
نقاش بانوراما من الخبر ما يفضل دانيال
خبير في استراتيجيات الطاقه ومن باريس
الدكتور حسن ليلي المتخصص في سياسات
التنميه والبيئه شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]